[Music]
nothing stuck to mafia boss John Gotti
who evaded justice for years by bribing
and threatening jurors and witnesses
that earned him the name the Teflon Don
after one of the slipperiest materials
on earth Teflon
was in the spacesuits the Apollo crew
wore for the moon landing in pipes and
valves used in the Manhattan Project and
maybe in your kitchen as the nonstick
coating on frying pans and cookie sheets
so what is the slippery solid and why
doesn't anything stick to it Teflon is a
brand name for polytetrafluoroethylene
or PTFE it was stumbled upon
accidentally in 1938 by a 27 year old
American chemist named Roy Plunkett
while he was trying to develop a
non-toxic refrigerant fluid for DuPont
a chemicals company the strange white
substance that formed inside his lab
canister was chemically inert meaning it
wouldn't react with other substances it
also had an extremely low coefficient of
friction making other materials slide
right off it teflon properties make it
perfect when you need something slippery
chemical resistant or waterproof which
means it has a lot of applications it
can be found all over the place as a
coating on raincoats industrial ball
bearings artificial joints circuit
boards and even the Rocky Mountains
themed roof of the Denver International
Airport the incredible properties of
PTFE come from its molecular structure
it's a polymer meaning it's made of long
chains of repeating units of atoms
strung together
PTFE chain has a backbone of carbon
atoms each of which is attached to two
fluorines the fluorine atoms surround
the carbon like armor
spiraling around the chain and the bond
between carbon and fluorine is
incredibly tight like a couple that
ignores every one except each other
carbon and fluorine interact so strongly
that the normal intermolecular forces
that help substances stick to each other
don't stand a chance even the famously
adhesive feet of geckos usually can't
get a grip but wait if PTFE doesn't
stick to anything how can it be so
firmly attached to something like a pan
one method involves sandblasting the pan
or etching it with chemicals to make it
rough then a special primer is applied
which acts like glue
its exact composition is a trade secret
guarded by each manufacturer the pan is
sprayed with liquid PTFE and heated to
around 800 degrees Fahrenheit the layers
then solidify into a smooth slick
coating when you later cook eggs in this
PTFE coated pan the extra tight
carbon-fluorine bonds just ignore the
water and fat and protein molecules in
the eggs without those interactions the
food just slides around without sticking
you might wonder if it's safe to cook in
a PTFE coated pan the answer is yes if
you're careful PTFE is stable at
moderate temperatures like you'd use to
cook eggs or fish but above 500 degrees
Fahrenheit it starts to degrade and
heating it further releases fumes that
can make you feel sick an empty pan can
reach 500 degrees fast over high heat
but most kitchens are ventilated well
enough to dissipate the fumes people
used to also think that accidentally
consuming PTFE that flaked off a
scratched pan was bad for you but the
current consensus is that it's harmless
because PTFE doesn't interact with other
chemicals very well it isn't thought to
break down inside your body whether it's
safe to manufacture teflon is another
story DuPont and its spin-off company
Kem Moore's now face lawsuits worth
millions of dollars they've been accused
of polluting the environment for
and exposing employees and local
communities to health risks associated
with a toxic chemical called PFOA that
chemical was involved in manufacturing
teflon as for John Gotti in 1992 the mob
boss was finally convicted of five
counts of murder among other charges
that prompted the head of the FBI office
in New York City to announce the Teflon
is gone the dawn is covered in Velcro
and all the charges stop
you
[Music]